[Música]
es momento de la revista de prensa con
Rosa Pérez en más deu en directo América
Rosa Buenos días para usted Buenos días
Ángela y el tema evidentemente Putin y
su discurso el Moscú Time se lo reporta
y dice Rusia promete continuar con el
combate en un discurso del estado de la
unión en tiempos de guerra cuéntenos
exactamente y lo que destaca más este
medio ruso pero que tiene la redacción
en Países Bajos recordemos es que Putin
reitera la acusación hacia occidente de
que le obligó digamos a invadir Ucrania
decirlo Putin en estas palabras no citan
un fragmento del discurso en que el
presidente ruso dice la responsabilidad
de alimentar el conflicto ucraniano de
su escalada del número de víctimas recae
completamente en las élites occidentales
unas élites que según Putin tienen un
objetivo real digamos Pero ha escondido
que es acabar con Rusia habla también el
New York Times qué es lo que destaca
este medio del discurso pues en estos
momentos está destacando como gran parte
de la prensa internacional uno de los
últimos anuncios que ha hecho Putin en
su discurso Y es que retirar Rusia al
menos suspende su participación de
momento del tratado de armas nucleares
es tecnificando así dice New York Times
una mayor ruptura con occidente hablamos
del tratado New stark que recordemos es
la prolongación de una serie de tratados
de desarme nuclear que empezaron durante
la Guerra Fría en New York Times lo
define como el único acuerdo de control
de armas nucleares que mantenía con
Estados Unidos y una de las cosas que
cambia de titular en titular más que la
información en sí es la forma de
calificarla no y en el New York Times
por ejemplo lo que vemos que no
encontraríamos en la prensa rusa es el
falsamente este adverbio en el titular
Putin acusa falsamente a occidente de
empezar la guerra dice New York Times
que Putin Por el momento no da signos de
tener los combates ni de Buscar diálogos
de paz y también señala el simbolismo de
que Putin hable horas antes que bailen
bueno el objetivo aquí es de contraste
Cómo abordan el discurso de los medios
rusos que son el comerciantes bedomoti y
sputnik usted nos trae esos ejemplos
exacto y todos destacan a esta hora ya
está suspensión de la participación de
Rusia en el tratado New stark también
citas de Putin como que occidente
convirtió un conflicto local en uno
global una frase reiterada no por el
presidente ruso a lo largo de este año
también destacan que Putin ha anunciado
ayudas para veteranos de guerra o para
combatientes en la operación militar
especial también que las sanciones no
están funcionando también la necesidad
de integrar logísticamente las regiones
anexionadas unilateralmente por Rusia
del donbas y agradeció todo el pueblo
ruso su heroitismo y señaló que las
elecciones presidenciales en 2024 se
realizarán con normalidad también pidió
un minuto de silencio por los muertos en
el donbas literalmente a manos de
neonazis o por último también ejemplo la
necesidad de proteger a los menores
rusos de la degradación y la decadencia
de occidente Ahora hay más aristas en
esta semana de aniversario de la Guerra
de Ucrania y está el relato que destacan
algunos medios de Rusia para
supuestamente absorber velarus en el año
2030 Exactamente no recordemos que
belarus de hecho fue uno de los frentes
desde donde Rusia entró a invadir
Ucrania en este caso según un documento
del centro dossier recordemos es un
centro de estudios de la oligarca y
opositor Ruso
mijadrovski al que han tenido acceso a
distintos medios de comunicación Rusia
tendría un plan para absorber
gradualmente velarus para 2030 tomando
el control de la política la economía y
el potencial militar del país vecino No
aparte de asumir mayor presencia y mayor
control de estas áreas también pretende
según este documento dar por ejemplo la
ciudadanía rusa a los bielorrusos porque
todo esto bien para atenuar la
influencia dice de las fuerzas
nacionalistas y pro occidentales y
fortalecer el sentimiento prorruso en
las élites de belarus según el kiev
independent que cita al embajador de
Estados Unidos en la osce Michael
Carpenter los objetivos rusos en velarus
son los mismos que en Ucrania solo que
en belarus Confía en la coerción en
lugar de la guerra bueno expansionismo
que claramente ha mostrado Vladimir
Putin vamos a cerrar con una nota que
encuentra usted en el post y habla de
cómo viajó yubaiden hasta aquí sin que
nadie se enterara exactamente este medio
ucraniano señala que esta misión fue una
de las más complicadas y de mayor riesgo
imaginables no porque Joe biden como
cualquier presidente estadounidense es
uno de los hombres más observados del
planeta y era muy difícil llevarlo Pues
a una zona de Guerra sin bueno que y que
pasara desapercibido Y que llegara ileso
no esta operación para llevarlo hasta
aquí empezó nos dice este artículo en el
aeropuerto militar a las de Washington a
las cuatro am de la domingo hora de
Washington en un avión más pequeño de El
que habitualmente usa el presidente
estadounidense para viajar no todo para
despistar un poco y en una zona alejada
de un embarcar el presidente
estadounidense y un detalle todas las
persianas en todo el recorrido
estuvieron siempre bajadas quien viajaba
con él un grupo más reducido de lo
habitual un grupo de seguridad de
médicos consejeros y solo dos
periodistas A diferencia de los 13 de
los 13 periodistas que suelen viajar con
el normalmente para terminar rápidamente
estas periodistas eran la redactora
Sabrina Wall Street journal y El
fotógrafo Evan bouche de social Express
hicieron una parada en Alemania para
repostar combustibles siempre con las
persianas del avión bajada otra en
Polonia donde cogieron un tres un tren
de 10 horas hacia aquí efi señalan que a
diferencia de cuando los presidentes
visitan zonas de conflicto en este caso
no eran las tropas estadounidenses las
que proporcionaban la seguridad y por
último Jake Sullivan consejero de
seguridad Nacional de Estados Unidos
dice notificamos a los rusos que biden
viajaría a kiev algunas horas antes de
despegar con el propósito de evitar el
conflicto Qué tal el privilegio de sus
periodistas Sí señora bueno Rosa gracias
a usted Gracias